but we begin this morning with the
growing uproar after two black lawmakers
were expelled from Tennessee's
legislature Democratic Representatives
Justin Jones and Justin Pearson were
removed by Republicans for taking part
in a pro-gun control protest inside the
house chamber last week the protest
followed the Nashville school shooting
that left six dead a third Democrat
Gloria Johnson escaped expulsion by just
one vote protesters at the state capitol
denounced the vote and President Biden
called it shocking undemocratic and
without precedent Mark Strassman is
outside the capital of Nashville Mark
good morning
good morning Natalie never before has a
Tennessee lawmaker never mind two
Tennessee lawmakers been expelled on
partisan grants but in a polarized
country the gloves are off
they walked in hand in hand as the
Tennessee three only one walked out
still a lawmaker Tennessee
Representatives Justin Jones Gloria
Johnson and Justin Pearson addressed
their colleagues in Nashville but
Americans all over were also watching We
Shall Not Bow I have to raise the voice
of the people in my district our Silence
about gun violence is the antithesis of
what is in the best interest of the
people of the state of Tennessee power
to the people here's why the three
Democrats had their seats on the line
last week's protest on the state house
floor with a bullhorn they were angry
about the lack of debate over gun laws
after the slaughter at Nashville's
Covenant School last week just because
you don't get your way you can't come to
the well bring your friends and throw a
Tipper tantrum with an adolescent
bullhorn outraged Republicans here have
a super majority more than enough votes
to expel the three Democrats what is
happening here today
is a force of democracy Justin Jones
defended himself first defiant
passionate about the jury I hear about a
clair of Representative Justin Jones of
the 57 representative district expelled
Gloria Johnson went next a former
teacher who had a student die in a
school shooting it's the guns it's the
people that have the guns because we are
not doing anything to make sure that
people who are not safe
don't have guns the measure to expel
Johnson failed by one vote finally
representative Justin Pearson spoke I
don't personally want attention
what I want is attention on the issue of
gun violence but instead we're here with
the resolution you put up talking about
expelling me for advocating for ending
gun violence in the state of Tennessee
Pearson like Jones expelled a state in
which the Ku Klux Klan was founded
is now attempting another Power grab by
silencing the two youngest black
Representatives after the hearing
Johnson was asked why her seat was saved
while the other two lawmakers lost
theirs it might have to do with the
color of our skin
allegations of racism were both part of
the debate and the reaction after the
vote white Republicans expelled two
lawmakers both young black men both
Jones and Pearson could run for their
seats again in a special election but
the question in the minds of a lot of
people here is should they really have
to
Vlad yeah we'll be watching Mark
Strassman thank you very much